[Music]
megan is in trinity florida hi megan how
are you
hey good dave how you doing better than
i deserve what's up
merry christmas i have a christmas
question for you okay so i'm uh we are
baby steppers four five and six we are
bsms we're about six months shy of
paying off our house
i wanna buy my husband a really nice
christmas gift what is that
what do we do well we want to get him
golf clubs like three thousand dollars
now okay
and so i'm wondering like what do we do
as far as transparency you know i don't
want him to know about it well don't
tell him aren't you gonna have those if
you're gonna buy a nice set of golf
clubs aren't they gonna be fitted
well probably but if i just buy like
this certificate to give him on
christmas day
or something like that i got an idea or
just in general i got it dave and i both
love golf so we'll tag team this so
dave's right he's going to want to be
fitted these are really nice clubs i i
say get him a really nice golf bag one
of the stadium bags that'll stand up on
its own like tour level and then you
kind of put some kind of note or
whatever your creativity would be to
reveal why you've got given him an empty
golf bag he's going to be excited about
the bag potentially if you can get a
hold of his golf buddies and they can do
some research for you that's one way to
present
the golf clubs and that the fact that
he's going to be fitted yeah you don't
have to pre-pay for him yeah
okay you give me a box of golf and give
him a box of golf balls with an envelope
the whole thing getting my entire outfit
the bag i mean everything i'm trying to
get this guy more presents right now
what's going on
like how does he go about getting me
something and surprising me because i'm
the one that does all the finances
oh i have the answer to that too dave
because because
so when because stacy handles most of
the administrative stuff because if you
know me you know that that's a good
thing
and uh so uh every year when i get her
her big thing uh we have an agreement we
have the budget for our gifts anyway so
that's all been cashed out until we've
got that and so i said hey i need you to
stay out of the account for uh a day or
two because everything's planned out i
just i don't want you to see it and wait
i handle it that way and she she honors
it
it's not that difficult
you guys trust each other
yeah well you guys trust each other
you're enjoying accounts you say hey
stay out of the account for a couple
days
perfect
thanks
easy enough there it is boy i like those
calls i was getting this guy clubs a
golf bag shoes the whole nine yards i
kind of like that
you're more about the outfit than the
actual golf yeah dave knows too much
about my golf game this is the fact